last night we're having dinner and we're
talking consulting our consulting
business has grown very rapidly
and we're getting more and more uh
uh
consultants that are coming over to us
and we're getting more people that are
calling us from mckinsey's guard you
know these bigger account consulting
firms that want to sell our product
right so they're reaching out to us one
of the things that a guy was talking
about how is a lot of lazy executives
nowadays in fortune 500 companies
they have an idea that they want to
bring up to the ceo okay so when they
want to bring up this idea to the ceo
and tom's talking about this last night
they say the best bet is i'll go to
mckenzie
and i'll say here's my idea here's a
half a million dollars can you
send me an analysis on why this idea is
good or bad
they send it to them and they'll say
here's why it's a good idea then they'll
go pitch it to their ceo or whoever the
bosses that they're working with and
they'll say here's my idea by the way
i've already spent a half a million with
mckenzie mackenzie already approved that
it's a good idea let's go ahead and test
it so that's their insurance policy to
say
if it succeeds awesome i get the victory
but if it fails look at least i went and
got my insurance policy from who from
mckenzie and mckenzie gave me
a thumbs up hey you're doing a good job
go for it you know kind of like backing
them up don't worry we'll take the blame
forward because of our and whatever
research that we gave you so it's an
interesting way of doing it so for me
intelligence do i trust a government
agency
that's been there for years to do it or
would i rather use an independent agency
that's more on the free market free
enterprise side
that has a reputation that if you don't
hit it negative reviews is actually
hurts a private agency
negative views doesn't do [ __ ] for cia i
can't go on yelp and find cia i can't go
on glassdoor and find cia i can't go
anywhere and do anything with fbi and
they're like dude say whatever you want
you can't do nothing about it so
maybe what happens with this with my
opinion is
even if i'm a president that gets
elected say i become a president
do i really trust a guy that's been an
agent for 22 years because in a way the
agent that's been there for 22 years or
27 years or the director that's been
there for 32 years he looks down at me
because in the back of his head he'll
say things like
dude you're only here for four years at
best if you're lucky maybe eight years
you ain't [ __ ] i've been here for 32
years who the hell are you
you're gonna come and put it on your
resume that you became a president and
you're out of here i don't care what
you're gonna be doing so me as a
president who gets paid to be paranoid i
sit there and i say why the hell would i
trust you to do the intelligence for me
because your loyalties to people that
came before me i'm gonna go use an
independent agency outside not in the
government because i don't trust you to
be honest with you
and then see what we can get so
do you see how there's a little bit of
that you know
distrust and the lack of respect a the
director of cio or director of fbi has
for whoever becomes a president and how
the lack of trust a president could have
for people that are currently in these
agencies yeah and you're exactly right
that that is what happens and then but
there's a second step that i think we're
overlooking because all of those
director positions are presidential
appointments
so i would say almost to a worse
detriment the president just brings in
whoever he wants to put in or whoever
she wants to put in and they become the
new director
right every president has the right to
appoint who they want and that's why
that's why uh that's why directors at
cia and directors at fbi and directors
of nsa change so frequently because they
don't come up from the inside they don't
spend 35 years at cia and become the
director they spend 35 years and become
some lackey to the director and the
director is appointed by the president
inside the president's inner circle of
friends or peers and then they get the
chop off from the senate
so even i would say it's almost worse
than what you're saying because the most
professional person in that organization
doesn't even have a chance of becoming
the director they have to make friends
with whoever the incoming president is
or even worse whoever the presidential
party represents
and then they will become nominated for
that role
and so that's the truth of how it works
and then to your second point which i
think is even more powerful america is
asking itself the question now should we
privatize intelligence
we
we failed massively on september 11 2001
massive intelligence failure because we
let the
the intelligence infrastructure at fbi
and cia run things the way they had
always run things through the cold war
and we had completely closed our eyes to
the fact that we were moving into a war
on terror afghanistan massive failure
predicting ukraine massive failure right
and now with 2016 president trump when
the cia turned its back on trump trump
just dried up funding and directed this
funding into a private intelligence
organization
so we have seen it work we've seen
people do it the precedent has been set
so now the government is asking itself
the question collectively
do we even keep doing it this way how do
we change how do we evolve how do we
evolve closer to the speed of business
and less to the speed of government it's
not going to happen though it's not
going to happen that's why you see
private intelligence on the rise right
now most of the people that sit inside
cia headquarters aren't
government employees they're contractors
that belong to booz allen hamilton
raytheon later i'm more comfortable with
that
but but that's the transition yeah i'm
more comfortable with that and i'm glad
i hope it goes that direction so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]